In the world of back-end development,
errors are not just problems to solve.
They are a normal part of building
applications. And every developer needs
to understand that errors will happen.
And the key is to being ready for them,
being ready to detect them, being ready
to fix them. And here is a reality. Your
database queries, they will sometimes
fail. your external APIs, they will
sometimes time out and your users will
sometimes send bad data which will break
your APIs if you're not ready for them
or if you are not expecting them and
your business logic will hit unexpected
edge cases sometimes. So the question is
not whether errors will happen but how
you will handle them when they actually
do. So in this video there are no tools
that I want to talk about. There are no
frameworks, there are no examples, code
snippets, nothing. It is a mindset. When
you are a backend engineer, when you're
responsible for executing your core
business logic, when you're responsible
for making sure every single
transaction, every single user activity
goes seamlessly. Then you need a
particular mindset, a fault tolerant
mindset so that you are prepared for the
worst and you know how worse it can get
and there are some things that you need
to keep your eyes on and there are some
tips on how to detect them and how to
prevent them. What are the best
practices people usually implement?
whether it's a startup, whether it's a
big enterprise or open-source
repositories, etc., etc. Let's start
with what are the different types of
errors that you might encounter in your
day-to-day life as a backend engineer.
The first type, I think this is the most
common type, which logic errors. Logic
errors. Now, these are the sneaky ones.
It's not always very easy to detect them
or to fix them. Logic errors are
probably in my experience the most
dangerous type because they don't crash
your application as such but they just
make it do the wrong thing. Your code
which you have written it runs fine but
the results are incorrect. The results
are unexpected. So to take an example
let's say we have an e-commerce store.
you are a back end engineer in a
e-commerce kind of SAS application and
this store that accidentally applies a
discount twice and that gives customers
negative shipping costs. The app does
not really crash in this particular
scenario. But now your uh platform, the
platform that you are working for as an
engineer, your platform is losing money
and it is losing money on every single
order because of this one logic issue.
Now these errors can go unnoticed for
weeks and even months while quietly
causing problems if you don't you're not
monitoring them or if your users are not
reporting them and your platum is just
facing more and more loss every single
week. So when do they actually happen
and why do they happen? Some of the
common scenarios are for example if you
let's say misunderstand
requirements or you implement algorithms
incorrectly or if you just don't think
about edge cases. So these are some of
the usual scenarios when logic errors
occur. The first thing is
misunderstanding requirements. Let's say
your typical sprint cycle follows by
having a one-on-one discussion with your
client or with your product managers and
during those discussions some of the
points came across a little confusing
and you noted down the requirements
which were not the intended ones. So you
went ahead and implemented those and
that went straight to production and
with lack of testing it also went to the
users and it started causing problems.
So misunderstanding requirements is a
pretty common one. Then you might have
uh let's say it's a very complicated
algorithm depending on the user's
behavior and depending on the user's
past purchase history. You are issuing
different different discount codes and
different different discount workflows.
And in those complicated algorithms you
made uh one slight miscalculation and
that in turn caused all this discount
related loss in your platform. Or it
might be that you did not expect a
particular user activity, a particular
user behavior in a payment workflow in a
discount based workflow and that caused
some issue. So these are some of the
scenarios where logic related errors
might occur and they are pretty
dangerous ones. If we are talking about
payments or monies or uh security in
that aspect, they can corrupt data and
they can produce wrong business results
over time without getting detected. So
that's all about logic errors. Second
type is database errors. Now database
errors can bring your entire system down
since most backend apps they rely
heavily on their database. And these
errors range from a simple connection
problem to complex issues like deadlocks
and transaction related issues. And
connection errors happen when your app
cannot talk to your database. Your back
end throws a couple of 500 errors and
your front end just shows empty screen
everywhere. Or it can also be because
the network is down and the database
server is overloaded. Or you have run
out of connection pools. We you make use
of this concept called connection pools
so that your back end can hold a couple
of open connections to your database
server open TCP connections so that it
does not have to do the whole process of
TCP handshake and all every time a new
request comes. So database pooling is
kind of an optimization to prevent uh
TCP connection based setup costs. So in
a pooling based setup that can also
cause an error and when these errors
happen your app basically cannot really
function because your back end needs to
interact with the source of the data to
send something to the front end to and
the front end needs something to show
right. So if your database is down if
your database is throwing error then
your whole platform your whole app
cannot really function properly. That's
about the first kind of database errors
which I just mentioned are connection
errors. Connection errors. Second thing
can be about constraint violation. Now
this is something which is not very
apparent. By constraint violation I mean
that you are trying to perform some kind
of operation which breaks the database
rules. For example, you might try to
create a user with an email that already
exists. In that case, your database just
throws a unique constraint error. And if
we'll come back to that in the later
part of the video, but if you are not
properly handling that error, the unique
constraint error and you're not sending
a properly formatted message to your
user to your front end, then that error
might bubble up to your to your main
process and it might throw a 500 error
to your front end. So that is one kind
of constraint violation, the unique
constraint violation. If you're trying
to create a user with the same email or
it can also be that you are trying to
reference a customer that does not
really exist in another table. For
example, you have two tables. One is
customers and second is orders. So in
the orders table you have a field called
customer ID and this is a foreign key to
this table and this is let's say not
nullable and you are trying to insert a
new record into the orders table with a
customer ID which does not really exist
in the customer table and since it is a
foreign key and you are referencing the
customers table the database throws an
error if it cannot find a associated
entry in the customer's table. So that
can also be a cause of constraint
violation. And the reason for these
kinds of violation, the constraint
violation is usually lies in your
validation layer. If you're not properly
handling all the edge cases both in your
front end and your back end, then these
kinds of constraint violation error
might occur. So that is something to
keep in your mind in order to avoid the
database constraint violation related
errors. Then you have to make your
validation layer stronger. But of course
the constraint violation errors like
unique key errors they cannot be
avoided. Only the database knows whether
a new entry a new email is unique or
not. So for those use cases of course
you have to focus on your error
formatting. How to send a properly a
user-friendly message to your front end
so that your front end can show a proper
message that try a different email this
email already exists something like
that. And then in the database we have
another kind of error which is called
query errors. Query errors basically
happen when your SQL is malformed. For
example, you are trying to access tables
that don't exist because you made a typo
in your SQL query. Let's say you wrote a
query something like select star from
customers. This is a proper query. But
instead of writing this, you ended up
writing something like you made a typo
and that caused an error that this table
that you are trying to query from this
does not really exist. So that is a
error which happened because of a typo a
malformed SQL query or it can also
happen when your queries are too complex
and they time out etc. deadlocks.
Deadlocks are another reason. Deadlocks
are particularly tricky and they occur
when multiple database operations are
waiting for each other and they create
kind of a circular dependency. Now
that's where we have a dreadlock kind of
situation. So that's also something you
have to be worry about. Next we have
external service errors. uh most of the
modern apps that we have uh these days
SAS applications mostly that we are
talking about they depend on a lot of
external services external services like
uh payment processors or email providers
or let's say cloud storage stoages like
object storage like S3 or radius or
let's say you are using a external
provider something like oz0ero or clerk
for your authentication system so that
is also an external dependent dependency
and each one of these external
dependencies is a point of failure that
you don't really have any control over
and that is a big problem and you cannot
really avoid that. It's not like you can
abandon using any external dependency
that's not possible because you have to
build a lot of systems from scratch a
lot of complex systems that people have
spent years of effort on. So that is not
really something that is practical. So
you have to expect that all these
external services might fail and you
have to be prepared that when they fail
these are the things that we are going
to do to make it up for our users and
couple of reasons why these external
services might fail. First thing is of
course network. This is how we from our
backend application connect to an
external services either through HTTP or
through TCP or through websocket any
other kind of connection. But the
backbone the medium is of course the
network the internet and the internet is
not really perfect. So you'll have to
deal with things like connection
timeouts and DNS failures and network
partitions. This is affected by your
routing etc. Partitions right and you
need to expect this and you need to plan
for them. For example, let's say you are
using a authentication provider
something like clerk or something like
ozero. Another thing to keep in mind
when you're using an external provider
is authentication errors happen when
external services like clock or ozero
they reject request due to either
because bad credentials the username
password is not correct the email is not
correct or expired tokens or
insufficient permissions etc. So just
because you're using an external
services for your authentication is not
secure enough in itself because you are
using them as an integration you still
have your own back end they are not
standalone and in your own back end you
can cause security issues security
issues like you might expose sensitive
user informations in your logs etc. So
that is something that you have to keep
in your mind since we are talking about
external dependencies authentication
etc. I just thought of mentioning this
point. Now, next thing is rate limiting.
When you are using external services,
let's say you are integrating some kind
of AI functionality and you are using an
open AI key or you are using something
like resend for your emails etc. And
these external services they pretty much
all of them have this functionality
called rate limiting. And rate limiting
exists so that their users so our
external services let's say an email
provider like resend and we are their
users business users but still users we
cannot abuse them. They prevent
malicious users who send abnormal amount
of request in a particular time frame
and they have mechanisms rate limiting
mechanisms implemented so that they can
prevent uh users like us and users with
bad intentions and for some reason let's
say your platform because of some kind
of user activity in your platform or
let's say some kind of logic errors you
ended up hitting their API a abnormal
amount of times. and it started failing
because and their rate limiting
algorithm triggered and they started
blocking you or sending you 4 to 9. So
we get the response code 4 to9 when we
make too many requests. It means too
many requests and you started getting
this error code 429. So in these kinds
of scenarios you have to expect them
from beforehand and you have to be ready
for them. And by be ready for them, I
mean you have to implement strategies.
Strategies like let's say exponential
backoff. Exponential backup is a pretty
common strategy that we usually
implement in case of rate limiting
related errors. For example, once we
start getting 4 to9 requests. So we have
a condition in our error handling logic
that if we start getting 4 to 9 then
wait for a minute wait for 2 minutes
then try again. If you still get 4 to 9
then wait for double that amount of
time. If we previously waited for 2
minutes now we'll wait for 4 minutes and
we'll try again and until we start
getting successful responses we'll keep
doing this. That's why it's called an
exponential backup strategy. So in order
to deal with rate limiting errors you
have to implement these strategies.
Strategies like exponential backoff. And
the last one when you are dealing with
external dependency the most inevitable
one is service outage or service going
down. Now this we see pretty much
happening every once in a while. Let's
say some major cloud provider something
like GCP or something like some services
of AWS face some kind of issue some kind
of incident and they go down and when
they go down a lot of their clients go
down and we have this u chaos in the
internet in the Twitter that this
service is down these users are
complaining etc. So external services
going down is something we as software
engineers don't really have a lot of
control over. They are inevitable and
sometimes they go down because of
unexpected incidents or sometimes they
go down because of maintenance and your
app your back end needs to handle these
kinds of errors also gracefully either
with fallbacks you have to have let's
say your radius service goes down then
you should have a second layer of backup
something like in-memory caching or a
second radius node etc like some kind of
fallback so that your app can handle
that gracefully and without affecting
any kind of major user functionality
like payments or something like order
processing etc. In the next category we
have and this is a famous one input
validation errors and these are
something which happen because of users
in our platform because of the consumers
of our platform. Input validation errors
happen. They happen because users uh
send bad data that does not really meet
our requirements, meet our system
requirements, meet our rules and the
validation layer which throws these
errors. This is our first line of
defense against any kind of bad data or
malicious inputs since we are detecting
at the entry point in our backend
application and we are just throwing
errors if something does not meet our
requirements. And there are different
types of rules that we usually enforce.
If you watch the validation video in
this playlist, then you'll have a much
deeper understanding about the different
kinds of validation that we like to do.
But usually it's something like format
validation where we check if let's say
an email is an appropriate email format
or not, whether a phone number looks
like a phone number or not, or a date is
an appropriate date or not, etc., etc.
And you need to be clear even if it's
some kind of custom data we need to be
clear what exact format that we are
expecting and we should only accept that
format for the sake of security for the
sake of fall tolerance. We also have
range validations that handles numeric
inputs whether the maximum amount is too
high or the minimum amount is too low
etc or if the string is too long or if
it is too short. If the array has at
least three items or if the array has
more than 100 items, things like this
are called range based errors. We also
have required field validation and this
check if a particular field which is
mandatory for a particular operation to
happen is present or not. If they are
not present then we throw an error and
usually in these kinds of errors we
throw a 4handed which is a bad request
error from back end and these kinds of
errors are the easiest ones to expect
and the easiest ones to handle because
we already know the requirements of our
data and we just enforce those rules at
the entry point of our backend
application and if anything seems off we
just throw an error right unlike the
other kinds kinds of errors that we saw
above which are external dependency
which we don't really have any control
over logic errors which are hard to
detect. It's a validation errors are the
easiest ones to handle. So make sure you
have a very robust validation layer.
Does not matter what kind of backend app
that you are building. Next up we also
have configuration errors. What does
this mean? Configuration errors can
prevent your app from starting if you
have that kind of setup in your app,
which you should have. And they also can
make your production environment behave
unexpectedly. And these kinds of errors,
configuration errors, they usually show
up when you are moving between your
development, your staging and your
production environment. For example,
while development, you added a
particular environment variable. Let's
say something like open AI API key. You
added this in your env file and you
raised APR and it is merged and you
forgot to add this particular variable
in whatever your production environment
variable flow is whether it is manual or
whether it is coming coming from AWS
parameter store etc etc and you just
forgot to add that there and the
deployment went successful from this
point. If you forgot to add that two
things can happen. If you are checking
at the start of your application, you're
validating the presence of all the
required environment variables. If you
have that kind of setup in your back
end, then your app fails to start. And I
think this is the best case scenario.
That's why if you are building a backend
app, make sure your environment variable
or your configuration settings whatever
that you are reading either from
environment variables or from remote
stores whatever all these variables
which are required for your app to
function properly which are not
optional. Make sure you validate them at
the first step before your server
starts. And if any of them are missing,
if any of them are corrupt, then fail
your app there. So that when you make a
new deployment and since most of the
deployments have kind of a setup like
blue green deployment where unless the
new deployment is successfully starts,
the previous deployment does not really
stop. So if you push something and a new
deployment starts and it fails, your
previous deployment is still running and
uh your app is not really down. As
compared to another scenario where
you're not doing this kind of setup
setup where at the start of your app
you're checking all the required
environment variables, the configuration
variables are present or not and you're
not throwing any kind of error. You're
not stopping your app. But because of
this kind of setup, what happens in your
API handlers? API handlers which make
use of this new OpenAI service to make
an API call to the OpenAI servers to
let's say generate some kind of image or
something. So when that API is finally
hit by some user then uh this service is
triggered and since that service tries
to access this particular configuration
variable which is open a API key and it
cannot find it and it errors out and
your users get a 500 errors fails during
runtime and this is the worst case
scenario. We always prefer to crash our
app at the start before it it starts to
serve real users as compared to this.
This is a bad scenario is something
which should not happen. So that's all
about configuration errors. It happens
when we are moving between development,
staging, production and it is pretty
common. So in order to prevent these
kinds of errors, make sure you have this
kind of setup where before you start
your app, you are validating all your
required configuration variables. In the
next video in the series, we are talking
about configuration management of
backend apps. So there we'll do a deep
dive on what kind of configuration that
we need, where to store them etc etc.
But just to give a high level advice
that make sure you validate your
configuration variables before your
server starts so that you can avoid
these sneaky kind of errors while your
application is running your while your
back end is running. Now let's talk
about prevention. Since we discussed
what are the different kinds of errors
that might happen and what are the
things that you have to keep an eye on
have to make a note of. Let's see what
we actually can do. So in my opinion one
of the best strategy is finding errors
before they spread. This is the best
strategy does not matter what
environment that we're talking about
whether we are talking about front end
backend infrastructure does not matter.
Finding errors the moment they happen
before they cause any actual damage that
is the best strategy a any kind of
system can have the best kind of error
handling. So this is the key point in
this video which is the best error
handling starts before error happens.
This is your key strategy and it should
be the best kind of error handling. It
starts before errors happen. So health
checks are fundamental in this. They
continuously monitor your system. We
typically have if you are talking about
monitoring your servers HTTP servers
then we expose a endpoint something like
health or something like status in an
endpoint which will return some kind of
generic response that it is okay. The
key thing is not the response it returns
the response code is important. As long
as it returns a 200 response code it
means that it's running. If it's
returning something like 400 or
something like 500 then something is
wrong. So that's why you make use of
health checks so that any external
service any external tool can keep
pinging keep hitting this particular
endpoint to make sure that it is active.
It is error-free. But this only checks
whether they are running or not your
services and your servers are running or
not. But that is in itself not enough.
You should not just check if the
services are running. You should also
check and you should also verify that
they are really doing their job. And
when we are talking about that, first
thing that comes to mind is databases.
To make sure that your back end is doing
its job, the primary component that
comes to mind is databases. And for that
we also have database based health
checks. and database based health checks
they test connectivity whether we are
whether we can successfully connect to
our databases or not and things like
query performance if some of the queries
which used to take let's say 500
millconds they have suddenly started
taking 4 seconds or 5 seconds then there
is something wrong or the data integrity
things like that a simple ping or a
simple health check endpoint which only
checks that our server is running or not
that in itself is not enough. Running a
representative query and checking the
results how much time it took and how
much time it takes on average etc etc.
And the second thing in our pack is of
course the external services. Now we
should also implement some kind of
health check kind of functionality for
our external services to make sure that
we can successfully connect to them and
they are functioning as they are
supposed to function. For example, for
payment processors, you can implement
test transactions so that when an actual
transaction happens from a user side, we
already know that since the last test
transaction 5 minutes back was
successful, then we are good to go. when
it comes to real transactions with real
users. Same way for email services, send
test messages to your internal email
addresses to make sure that the emails
are delivering and your connectivity can
be established with the external service
etc etc. Same way for authentication
services, you can generate test tokens.
You can test those tokens against
validation endpoints that your
authentication service exposes. And that
way you can verify that your
authentication service is functional.
And the last thing is core
functionality. These tests basically
involves that your configuration. As I
mentioned just before this point that at
the start of the app we should make sure
that all the required configuration
variables are present. If they're not
present then we are stopping at that
point and showing a meaningful message
so that whichever operator the wagon
operator the infrastructure operator
they can appropriately configure those
variables and start the service again
successfully. So making sure that the
configuration is properly loaded. The
caches some of the default caches the
caches which are necessary to run on
production workload they are populated
and some of the internal data structure
whether it's about configuration or
about external service etc etc they are
consistent. So these are called some of
the core functionality. So we should
also keep an eye on these things. So all
of this combined we can say that these
are proactive error detection ahead of
time making sure we are already prepared
for all these worst case scenarios and
we have methodologies to prevent them
and if they occur to fix them. So that's
why we call all of these as proactive
error detection. Then one of the major
components especially when we are
talking about error handling and fault
tolerant systems then this is something
which will always show up which is
monitoring and observability. Now this
is a huge topic logging monitoring and
observability and we have I think the
next to next video in this series is
going to be about logging monitoring and
observability that's why I don't want to
spend much time here in this video which
is all about the mindset that we need to
deal with errors right it's nothing
concrete just a scope to touch base upon
that's why we are not going to talk much
about monitoring and observability in
this video but The whole idea about
monitoring is it detects errors quickly
and while they are happening and it
provides enough context for us to debug
those errors. One point to keep in mind
in that area is don't just track if for
people who are already familiar with
practices of monitoring and
observability. One of the advices is to
don't just track error rates. Also
monitor performance metrics that might
indicate problems before they cause
failures. One of the early telltale
signs before a system is going to break
is the performance implications. If you
are seeing the degradation of
performance in some of your services,
then it might mean that they are going
to fail soon. So by monitoring
performance we can successfully avoid
some of the failures. Uh your monitoring
setup should track different types of
errors across different parts of your
application including uh HTTP errors,
database errors, external service
failures, business logic errors. It
should cover everything your monitoring
setup whatever service that you are
using for monitoring or whatever
methodology that you are implementing in
your back end. It should try to cover as
many sources of errors as possible. And
when we are talking about performance
metrics or performance monitoring, it
should track things like response times
or resource usage and throughput, your
business metrics monitoring. It should
keep track of performance indicators,
things like a sudden drop in successful
transactions, assuming you are running
some kind of e-commerce uh back end.
Then in a scenario like where the rate
of successful transaction suddenly drops
and you're seeing a lot of failed
transactions then it might indicate some
kind of technical problem even though
the error rates are normal. That's why
tracking business metrics metrics like
transactions successful authentications
etc etc that's also important. Then
logging good practices they provide
information you need to understand and
debug errors. You should implement
things like structural logging formats
like JSON logs which can be easily
passed and more metadata can be added to
it and tools like Graphana or Loki.
These external tools which are meant to
be log aggregation tools they can take
those logs the JSON logs and they can
appropriately parse them and you can
explore your error rates in a visual
dashboard kind of setup. You can search
through them, you can store them in
external storage etc etc. So that's
pretty much all about monitoring and
observability on a very high level. We
are going to dive deep into that the
tools that are usually used etc etc in a
future video but for now when it comes
to error rates and a fall tolerant
system monitoring and observability is a
key part to that. That's why we had to
mention it here. And next up I want to
talk about some of the philosophies that
have always helped me especially in the
scenario of error handling or building
robust systems. First thing is immediate
error response. Now when an error
happens your immediate response that
determines whether it becomes a minor
issue or a major failure and the
strategy depends on the error type and
the context of that error. For example,
for recoverable errors, things that we
already talked about the email sending
workflow. Let's say you have in an
external service something like resend
or sending an email and that service
failed. Now you are in a situation of
error handling. And if you think about
it, it is a recoverable error. Sending
an email is not something that has to
happen uh under milliseconds. We can
afford some kind of delay. So in
scenarios like these for recoverable
errors, retry mechanisms or exponential
backup strategies they are a good
solution and they work well for network
errors or temporary resources
or let's say we have run out of database
connections in our database. So in these
kinds of network errors or resource
utilization kind of errors in these
kinds of errors retry mechanisms
exponential backup strategies they work
quite well from my own experience but
something that you have to be careful
about is not to overwhelm already
stressed systems. So should keep the
error handling logic, whatever retrying
logic, whatever exponential backoff
logic that you're implementing, the
resource overutilization logic that you
have implemented, they should not add
more stress to your system since your
system is already under stress. That is
something that you have to keep an eye
on. And the second is nonreoverable
errors. The first one is that we talked
about sending an email or running out of
database connections in our pool. So
those are called recoverable errors. But
talking about non-reoverable errors, the
strategy that works best is containment
and graceful degradation. Containment
and graceful.
In this we usually do solutions like
switching to cast data or disabling
non-essential features or providing
alternative functionality providing some
kind of backup as a fallback and
containing the scope of that damage. So
that is a key strategy that we try to
implement in the cases of non-reoverable
errors. So that's about immediate error
responses. How should you react to two
different kinds of errors. One is
recoverable errors and the second is
non-reoverable errors. The second
thought or the second key idea is error
recovery strategies. Now this depends of
course on the error nature and the
functionality criticality. But automatic
recovery can handle many errors without
human interventions. For example, if a
service has failed and it is in a state
of not responding to any kind of
requests etc etc then restarting that
service automatically having some kind
of tool or some kind of setup in our
workflow for restarting that service or
that particular process works pretty
much all the time. Then implementing
cleanup functionality like cleaning up
corrupted caches. If we have problem
related to caches or switching to a
backup systems that also works most of
the time but you should design these
things carefully because some of the
times these things might make the
problems worse. You have to adopt a
trial and error based strategy. Try
these things. Try to reach that error
threshold ahead of the time and see what
works for you. What kind of error
recovery strategy works for what kind of
service. Now for some other kinds of
services, manual recovery is pretty much
necessary because it requires human
judgment and human decision making. So
for these kinds of errors which needs a
manual intervention, I should plan to
document these processes. So that all
your team members and your new hires are
aware of these kinds of workflows. What
to do in a situation of incident or any
kind of uh service failure and you
should test them so that you are already
prepared. you know that they are
definitely going to work when the
situation arises and they can be
executed quickly especially in a
stressful situation where taking
decisions quickly is the key to
providing a better user experience to
your user base and in scenarios like
these one of the key things to keep in
mind is not to corrupt your data. So
data recovery strategies data is the
most important part in your application
because all the other things are
basically the code that is running the
services that are running but the only
tangible thing is the data that you hold
the data of your user the data of all
your transaction of your orders or
whatever kind of platform that you are
building. So data integrity should be
one of your number one priorities. So
this should involve taking backups at
the key moments and restoring from
backups, replaying transaction logs
using specialized recovery tools. Third
thing is propagation
control. Not all errors should be
handled exactly the moment they occur.
Sometimes errors need to propagate up to
higher levels when there is more context
to the error. And we also use the word
stack trace in scenarios like these. But
you should have this kind of setup where
you are intentionally bubbling up your
errors to a particular process, the
primary process or the secondary
process. But you should have the whole
bubbling workflow in your control.
Otherwise, this might spread to other
services or it might shut down your main
service. We have this concept called
exception handling in most programming
languages. whether we are dealing with
JavaScript or Python where we have this
exception based workflow we we handle
errors using try catch. So these
exception handling hierarchies provide
the structure for error propagation. So
catching lower level exceptions and
wrapping them with enough context and
bubbling them up to higher level
exceptions so that we have more business
context so that we have enough
information in our hands so that we can
log the appropriate data. We can send a
meaningful error to our front end or if
we need to we can trigger some kind of
recovery strategy at that point. So
planning this whole thing bubbling up
the low-level error up to our highle
process with enough context that is
something which is pretty common that we
implement in pretty much all our backend
applications. We also have a different
name for this which is called global
error handling and we'll come back to
that in the next point. So error
boundaries these boundaries where the
last point where we stop the errors from
propagating further these error
boundaries in service architecture
especially they prevent errors in one
service from affecting others. So that's
the reason we should aim to use separate
processes and implement timeouts things
like timeouts which protect service
level boundaries and use things like
message cues to decouple different
different services instead of having
them in the same process. uh we should
implement things like rabbit MQ
different other kinds of message Q-
based architecture so that we have a
asynchronous communication between two
different services so that a bug in one
service does not cause the failure of
another service now coming back what I
like to call as the final safety net
global error handling final safety net
is one of my favorite error handling
mechanisms something which I pay a lot
of attention to in pretty much every
backend app that I have built with is
because this is one of those modules
which you spend a lot of time initially
when you're setting your whole platform
up when you are getting to know the
features that you might need the
services that you are using etc etc but
from that point on you only make slight
tweaks or add more conditions to check
etc etc but this is a one-time effort
And this is a single effort which pays a
lot in the future, not even in the
distant future, the immediate future
because this is the most important error
handling strategy you can implement in a
backend app. A global error handling
workflow. So this is how it typically
works. I want to explain this global
error handling workflow using real life
workflows that we typically use in
backend apps. So from our earlier videos
that we already know in a very common
backend architecture we usually have the
first entry point is of course the
routing layer. From there we reach the
handler. The routing layer decides which
handler is going to take care of a
particular request. And the handler
deals with taking or extracting whatever
data from that payload that we're
receiving the performing operations like
des serialization and validation and
binding etc etc. And once it has all the
appropriate data it calls a particular
service method we call it service
because in a typical service method we
might make use of one or more repository
methods. So service method is basically
an orchestrator for different repository
methods. Now what do we mean by
repository method? These are the leaf
nodes in a backend function which
usually do one thing and usually that is
running a database query. So we might
have functions like get user by id that
is a repository method and a service
might fetch a particular user by its ID
and then it might do additional
operations like it can fetch all the
users posts in the same service method
by calling a different repository
method. So one service which returns a
user and all its posts can call two
repository method. That's why we have
made this separation so that repository
methods are unit level. We try to keep
their scope limited to one single kind
of database operation and we let the
service the concerned service decide
what repository method and how many
repository method that it wants to call
etc. So in this architecture that most
back end apps follow when we are talking
about error handling let's say in the
repository layer so the route that we
are talking about let's say we we have a
a good readads kind of platform which is
a to oversimplify it a book management
book management platform and in a
typical endpoint of a book management
platform that we are trying to create a
new book. That's what we want to do. It
is a endpoint, an API endpoint. To
create a new book and to create a new
book, we want a couple of fields in our
payload. The first thing is name. Then
name of the book, which is a mandatory
field that we need to insert into the
database or let's say some optional
field called description. So these are
the two fields that we need to create a
new book. So there are different types
of errors that can happen in this
particular API. So first thing is let's
say so let's say in the entry point at
this point in our handler since the
handler performs operations like
validation etc then validation etc and
we have a business rule that the name of
the book cannot exceed more than 500
characters. We have this rule in our
violation layer and the user has sent a
new book name which is around 700
characters. So the data the payload
reaches our handler and in our handler
when the validation fails you want to of
course error out and return a meaningful
error to the user. So that is one kind
of error that can happen. Now going
inside we let's say passed the service
layer and we finally reached the
repository layer and in the repository
layer we have created a function a
function called insert new book and in
that function we are running this insert
query using SQL we are using posgress
imagining and we try to insert this new
book but we get a database error which
is a unique constraint violation error
which says that a book with this
particular name already exists in our
table in our books table that's why this
operation cannot be performed and we get
a database level error so that is a
different kind of error that we might
get so these are the two different kinds
of errors we might get in a single API
endpoint but the whole point of global
error handling is there are a couple of
advantages to it but the pattern usually
works by does not matter in what level
we uh get a new error or what kind of
error that is. Usually what we try to we
try to bubble that error up up to our
global error handler middleware. Usually
we try to keep our global error handling
in a middleware layer so that it has
access to all the incoming requests and
all the outgoing responses. So the aim
is to does not matter at what layer we
get a particular type of error. We try
to bubble that error up. So if it is a
exception handler kind of language let's
say something like JavaScript or Python
we just throw that error and we catch
that error in our middleware in our
final error handler or if it's a
language like Go where we return the
error then we keep returning the error
from our repository to our service to
our handler until it reaches our
middleware layer and the plan is to from
all these different places that a error
can arise and an error can be thrown
from for example from our repository
layer we might throw database errors
from our service layer we might throw
our internal errors and from our handler
layer we might throw validation related
errors and in every single programming
language we have this ability to create
custom errors. So in our final global
error handler middleware what we try to
do we read the error and depending on
what kind of error that is we perform
different different kinds of operation
and we return a particular kind of an
error response back to the user assuming
it's an userfacing backend application.
For example, if it is a validation
error, we return an error response back
to the user with the response code of
400 and whatever validation error
messages they need to fix their data. So
the first kind can be a 400 error. We
return a new HTTP message with the
response code of 400 which means bad
request. And we attach all the form
field related errors or any kind of
business logic error etc. and we let the
user fix them that came from the handler
layer. Second thing, the other scenario
that we talked about where the name of
the book already exists in our books
table that's why our database threw us a
unique constraint violation error and
for that in the global error handler
middleware we got a new error which is a
database error. Now even for a database
error we'll have different different
ways to deal with them and different
different kinds of message formats to
send to the user. For example, for this
use case for a unique constraint
violation kind of error the ideal
response since it is an error which was
thrown because of some data sent by the
user. So ideally we can send something
like a HTTP error with a response code
of 400 which is for bad request. We are
saying that this payload is a bad
request and because in the message we
can say that this is for the code HTTP
code and in the message field in HTTP
error we'll have an structure. So some
of the usual fields in an HTTP error
structure is a code the HTTP status code
which is 400 in this case a message or
any other form field related error data
which we usually send in a array in an
array of dictionaries or array of
objects or an array of JSONs. So in the
message field we can say that this this
book already book already exists in our
database or just book already exists and
this we did for a unique constraint
violation error. Same way let's say
there is a different API endpoint for
fetching the details of a single book.
So there is a URL in the front end a
user can go to this particular books and
in the book 1 2 3 when this is our front
end domain and when they navigate to
this particular route what we want to do
we in the front end we want to show the
details of the book and for the front
end to be able to show the details of
the book it has to call an API and our
back end serves that API uh in a similar
route in the back end also we have this
particular route And the front end makes
a request to this particular route the
books route with the path parameter of 1
2 3. So it reaches the handler uh it
goes through there is no particular
validation that we want to do for this
particular request since there is no
body and the ID is a number and that
passes the validation layer. It passes
the service layer and it finally reaches
the repository layer. In the repository
layer what we do? We run a select query.
So we do select star from books where
the ID of the book is 1 2 3. Right? You
can add a valid SQL query here. But for
the sake of this example, this is what
you want to do. You want to select a
particular book from the books table
whose ID is 1 2 3. Now assuming that
because of some malformed link or
someone trying to scam our user for any
kind of reason the front end the user in
the front end reach this particular
route but this book with this ID does
not really exist in our platform and the
front end made a request with this
particular ID and we reached our
repository layer and we ran this
particular query and because the book
does not exist the database through us a
no rows. So most of the drivers database
drivers especially in the relational
database field has this particular
common error which is no rows. If for a
particular SQL query especially for a
select query there are no rows for those
conditions the driver will throw an
error right there are no rows and what
we did we just bubbled it up so that our
global error handler can deal with it.
So that's why we reached here. So the
first kind of error that we talked about
that the global error handling
middleware has to deal with is unique
constraint violation error and same way
the second kind of error that we just
talked about is no rows error. So the
global error handling middle sees that
it is a database error and it is not a
uni constraint violation error. It is a
no rows returned kind of error. So for
this use case the data the error
handling middleware can see that it is a
route where a particular resource with a
particular ID was requested but the
database through error response and
because of this it can finally deduce
that this particular resource does not
really exist in our database and for
that kind of scenario we have an
appropriate error code which is the 404.
We use the 404 response code in HTTP
errors when we are trying to request a
particular resource but that resource
does not really exist. At this point the
error handling middle finally throws an
error with the code 404 and the message
that the book with ID 123 does not
exist. That is the second kind of
database error. Another different kind
of database error that comes to mind is
a foreign key violation error. So let's
take a scenario where we are talking
about a book management platform. So in
a particular endpoint we are creating a
new book with a new author and for that
endpoint for that API to work
successfully there has to be an existing
author and we have to pass the author ID
in the post payload in our body. So we
send a payload with the book name, the
book description which is optional and
an author ID. It passes our validation
layer and it finally reaches our
repository layer. And in our repository
layer, we are inserting we are running
an insert query. Insert into books name,
description, author ID with values
whatever the values the user has passed.
But for some reason the user or the
front end has passed an author ID which
does not really exist in our database.
And since in our database the books
table for the author id field for the
author ID column the constraint is it is
a foreign key which references a row
particular row in our authors table and
since there are no authors with that
particular author ID our database throw
us an error. This particular query
breaches the foreign key reference
violation error whatever. So that can be
another kind of database error that our
global error handling middleware has to
deal with. So for that scenario, what
can we do? If you think about it, the
front end passed a ID which does not
exist. The resource does not exist in
our database. So we can throw a 404
saying that this author ID does not
really exist. That's all about global
error handling middle. This is a final
safety net that I like to call it where
we can come up with and define different
different kinds of error that our
platform has to face throughout its life
cycle and we define all these rules
about how to deal with those errors and
what kind of responses to return to our
users. So it has two major advantages.
The first one is of course more robust
and secure because it does not matter
where in which layer an error occurs. We
are handling it in our final gateway in
our final middleware. It is considered
more robust since there is no way we'll
forget some kind of condition because if
let's say for a unique constraint
violation error if we did not have a
global error handling middleware and we
let the layers where the error actually
occurred to send a meaningful error
message to our users in that kind of
scenario. Let's say in our repository
layer unique constraint violation error
occurs. So it is the responsibility of
the repository layer to send a bad
request error to our user saying that
this book already exists in our
database. But for a particular
repository method, let's say we forgot
to add that condition and the database
function through an error. And since in
most of the backend setups if a
particular error is not appropriately
handled or appropriately identified and
dealt with what we do we convert that
error into a 500 error which basically
says that internal server error we don't
really know what happened something just
went wrong so try again sometimes later.
So the user instead of getting a
meaningful error message like the book
already exists in our database it will
get a 500 internal server error
something went wrong. So that is the
problem uh with not having a global
error handler and not having all your
error handling logic in a single place
that sometimes we forget to add all the
conditions. So in scenarios like those
having a final safety net which catches
all the different kinds of errors that
has a possibility to arise. The second
thing is connected to the same point
only which is reducing redundancy. If we
don't have a central point of error
handling logic, then all these different
kinds of error handling logic that we
have in a single file or a single
function, we have to spread them out in
all different layers and we have to let
that particular layer to handle those
kinds of error. For example, let's say
we discuss three different kinds of
database error that might occur in a
particular SQL query. So if we did not
have a centralized error handling logic
then for each repository method in every
place where we are executing an SQL
query we have to call a particular
function or we have to add all these
conditions that this is not a unique
constant violation error. This is not a
foreign key violation error etc. And if
it is that error then deal with it that
way. So that significantly increases the
redundancy of our code and it is also
prone to more bugs. Those are the two
major advantages of having a global
error handling logic in a single place.
Since we are talking about error
handling, the last two things that I
want to bring up is which is mostly
related to the security aspect of error
handling. So first thing that you have
to keep in mind is you have to be very
mindful about what kind of error
messages that you are exposing to your
users to your consumers. What kind of
details are leaving your backend app
which might compromise the security of
your application which might expose
information about some of your users
which can fall into wrong hands and they
can perform or compromise the security
of your users which are equally bad.
Whether it is compromising the security
of your platform or compromising the
security of your users, it is equally
bad. In fact, compromising the security
of your users is worse than your
platform because that harms your
goodwill, your trust in the market,
etc., etc. Now, it can happen in a
couple of places. The first one is you
have to make sure that whatever default
error handling mechanism in your back
end is whether it is in the global error
handler or whatever place you are
keeping it in it is not leaking any kind
of internal details back to the
consumer. For example, let's say you
your database threw some kind of unique
constraint violation error or some kind
of database error which has some details
about the table names or the indexes or
the constraint etc etc the internal
details of your database. So in your
global error handling middleware, if
you're just taking whatever error that
has bubbled up from your lower layers,
for example, in this case, the
repository layer and you're sending that
message back to the user in the message
field of your error structure, then that
can cause severe damage to your
platform. Because for advanced users,
for malicious users, they can take
details like your table names, your
constraint names, etc., etc. from your
database internal details and they can
try more advanced attacks, more advanced
forms of SQL injection. They can just
make your platform a target and they can
actively come up with more and more
strategies to bypass your security and
it will be harder for you to prevent
those kinds of attacks. So that is the
reason in all the error messages try to
have as much control as you can over the
messages. So try to understand what kind
of error is being thrown from whatever
layer it is being thrown from and
generate a message which is meant for a
user. For example, as I talked about in
your default error handling logic
instead of throwing a 500 and attaching
whatever message that bubbles up from
your lower layers add 500 and in the
message just say something went wrong.
Since if you have reached 500 which is a
default error handling mechanism which
means that in the previously you have
tried to check whether it is a
validation layer whether it is a
uniconent validation error whether it is
a business error etc etc you have
checked all the different kinds of
errors and finally you have reached this
stage where you don't really know what
kind of error that is. So for that kind
of situation you don't really want your
user to know what kind of error was
thrown. So it most probably has some
kind of internal details in the error
message and that is why in the default
error handling logic you always want to
have a generic message something like
something went wrong or the default
error message in most library which is
internal server error that is one aspect
the second aspect is let's say we are
dealing with a authentication or
authorization module let's say it is a
login endpoint you are expecting
expecting an email and password and
after you get the email and password
from the post request body you'll take
that you'll check from the email whether
a user exists or not if the user does
not exist you'll send an error and then
if the user exists you proceed you check
whether the password is correct or not
if the password is correct you'll throw
an error etc etc that's what comes to
our mind when we think about a login
endpoint but here also when we are
talking about error handling Something
that you have to keep in mind is
authentication is one of the most
targeted modules in most of the apps
that attackers malicious users usually
like to target. So in this case you have
to follow some of the security
practices. This particular resource
which is called OAS cheat sheet. This
resource has good practices and advices
for a lot of different kinds of
workflows. For example, authentication,
you'll get these different different
advices that don't do this, don't do
this, this will compromise your platform
in this way, this will compromise your
users in this way, etc. So, you can
follow some of the security practices
whatever is relevant to your use case
from a a resource like this. But uh the
whole idea is let's say we are talking
about a sign-in endpoint or a login
endpoint and in the first step you took
the email which was provided in the body
and you checked that whether a user with
this particular email exists or not. So
if the user does not exist with that
email instead of saying a user with this
email does not exist you should return
an error response which says that
invalid username or password invalid
email or password so that we can avoid
scenarios scenarios like let's say you
have a malicious user who is trying to
bypass some of the accounts of our legit
users or harmless users. So what
strategy they are trying to come up
with? So they are trying different
different email addresses and with
various passwords. If you are returning
very detailed error messages like a user
with this email does not exist or your
password is incorrect then what they can
do they can implement a step-by-step
approach for this attack. And what they
can do first they will try different
different emails with a single password
and for each email they'll keep getting
this message that a user with this email
does not exist a user with this email
does not exist and finally when they hit
an email for which a user exists since
we are naively returning error messages
they will get an error message saying
that your password is incorrect since
they are able to find an email for which
a user already exists in our platform.
Now they are getting an error message
which says that your password is
incorrect and now they have an email
which they know that a particular user
exist with this email. Now they can try
different different passwords uh common
passwords which have better chances of
getting a hit and with that they are
able to compromise the security of our
platform. So just using error messages
just using the weakness in our error
handling mechanism attackers malicious
users can compromise our security and
the security of our users. So that is
the reason try to follow security best
practices when it comes to error
messages. And the second thing which
comes to mind is especially in the
aspect of security is logs. On a very
high level, the idea is try to not
expose the sensitive information like
user's email, users passwords, their API
keys or their credit card numbers, etc.,
etc. in your logs, logs which you think
are limited to your own servers, your
own infrastructure, which are not
getting leaked to any kind of external
malicious user. But that's not how it
always works. In most of the major data
breaches, what happens since major
companies use external services,
multiple services to manage their logs
because for a particular company which
has a fair amount of user traffic, they
generate hundreds of GBs of logs every
day, right? And they have to use
multiple services, storage services,
analysis services, observability
services, different kinds of services to
manage their logs efficiently. So what
happens in these major data breaches the
company's logs gets leaked and from
these logs if they are not following
best security practices like not logging
users credit card numbers not logging
users emails not logging users passwords
API keys etc etc that detail gets leaked
and hundreds of malicious users have
access to them in case of errors let's
say authentication error occurs you
should not log any sensitive information
about the user always log user's ID ID
instead of their email and only
correlation ID so that you have enough
context. That's pretty much all I have
to say about error handling and creating
fall tolerant systems. This is mostly
theory just a couple of ways of looking
at systems and making the systems more
robust and keeping our mind open for
different kinds of errors and different
kinds of error handling mechanisms.